pepperoni flatbread pizza that's me
right here
no way no way
no way yes way
ben savage and danielle official just
reunited
on screen in the name of love and pizza
and seriously it's giving us all the
nostalgic boy meets world feels
i love your face and i love your hair
but most of all i love you because of
who you are
the actors who played corey matthews and
topanga lawrence on the hit series from
1993 to 2000
and the spin-off series girl meets world
from 2014 to 2017
teamed up for a valentine's day
commercial that pays tribute to
all of your favorite rom-coms like this
scene from pretty woman
[Laughter]
laughter or this moment where they're
sitting on a table
surrounded by candles a nod to this
classic moment from
16 candles
[Music]
it already came true
of course it wouldn't be a romantic
comedy without at least
one epic argument did you just take the
last slice of pizza
i didn't think you'd want it i wanted
you to want me to want it
yeah and that that was borrowed from
jennifer aniston
and vince vaughn's 2006 flick the
breakup
i just want you to want to do the dishes
why would i want to do dishes
and it's basically an unwritten rule
that you can't talk rom-coms without
including love actually
and this scene
[Music]
yeah ben and danielle did that too pizza
in one hand and a sweet love note
written on cardboard
in the other you're the pizza i never
knew i needed
if that isn't romance i don't know what
is
it is absolutely everything and it feels
so good of course you have to have a
heartfelt makeup scene
because when you know what you want for
lunch you want that lunch to start as
soon as possible
that's almost word for word when harry
met sally
i came here tonight because when you
realize you want to spend the rest of
your life
with somebody you want the rest of your
life to start as soon as possible
and get ready for the rom-com nostalgia
to end all
rom-com nostalgia you had me at
pepperoni
a little classic jerry maguire shut up
just shut you had me at hello
the throwback feels really are at a 10
out of 10.
and get this making it a full circle
moment
ben's older brother fred savage who
starred in the beloved dramedy the
wonder years
actually directed the whole thing no way
no way no way
you